I'm ready to go get a drink at eight
o'clock he was still light out yeah I
remember that warm evening would be able
to walk means after five o'clock be a
figure out at night she can't see I get
terrified so she's gonna get snatched
500 like a night bird the perch like
it's different now welcome to this video
i'm here with mamrie Hart and Hannah
Hart
wrote a book I've got this round came
out February 6 this past Tuesday and I'm
so excited about it and it's really
funny
and it's really cool and I'm also on
tour so go to memory muqaam to see if
I'm coming to a city near you
yeah just a new evolution of memory
unleashed well there's a story about
grace Helbig in here that'll make you
much fun because we were celebrating all
things memory in this Renaissance of
memory in her new book that we would go
back to some of our biggest best looks
oh because I don't know what look the
same way I don't know how it is look
somebody who wasn't told what this video
is about exactly I treat it out to you
guys tweet me what you think is
everybody did you question your favorite
Mary Hart look and we are like most
fashion reviews on the grace Helbig
YouTube channel just going to go through
and review some of the historical
archives the memory of art fashion
evolution my god do it do you judge this
round we'll find out
I know nervous I didn't choose any of
these I'm gonna pretend it if she's any
of these looks either there is no
particular order this is MIA Twitter all
of Mamre hearts best looks here we go
this is horrible
startup subtle and I wanted to give you
an evolution
I wrote a web series for my friend and
directed it she created like cool at
home all natural and so I gotta be
hilarious to test her makeup white if I
came in full kiss makeup makeup alone
you're clearly in the midst of not
giving up so that was like 5 a.m. and
you've got one eye half open and you
just escaped from prison you really
didn't dip a toe anyway they've jumped
into the deeply yeah I love that that's
a great memory love commands I ain't
gonna tiki drink you barefoot I'm in my
element this is from my last book tour
those tiki mugs were so short-lived
because we never cleaned them in between
shows I feel like they lived and died at
that show specifically I broke because I
went barefoot okay is this a show that
you reverse heckled hecklers you mean
every show I've ever done
also why is there some trash on stage oh
never mind the body language aside this
is at the Streamy Awards years ago and
maybe was partnered up with house barks
to present an award and he was I think
not you're the dick to me yeah hey REE
shut yeah he went off script and started
talking like in a tangent about the
internet when he's not a person from the
internet and then you just like let him
go and then you were like her anyway I
have many favorite memories dreamy
moments
this might be my favorite memory of our
red carpet look because it's one you do
badass really well thank you and this is
just like demure and like old Hollywood
it was a baby pic and what I loved is
that like the next award show everyone
knows where I'm a beep and you're like
transcend set the truck if I can I
forget it
no brakes and I like rotisserie chicken
infomercials Rumble real [ __ ] rest in
peace in peace you look so good in this
show that there is no sag in those SAG
Awards hey yo know what's next you build
me up we're literally just hanging out
shooting videos and you were like do you
guys want to go to the video game high
school per meter it was across town and
we're like if we were together it's
cheaper I also really cool these are
gonna be ok it's free drinks great we'll
go so we all went and like did the best
we could what was happening but there
was less do that but we also got there
way after the red carpet was done being
John and they were like no no no you
guys coming the red carpet and we all
came a little drunk to begin with
alright yeah we'll do the red carpet
sure I like your look on your face God
look like it's coming you didn't have
that wrong but she's got this round
don't worry come on this is Austin Texas
last year's South by Southwest yeah you
guys went to play golf kicking it off
I forgot how cool your jacket was I run
your jacket once I need to bust it out
it's just a sad jacket covered in
hamburgers or to catch up mom dude it's
also one of those when you're so hung
over you know
I'm gonna make people think I'm making a
statement I know what I'm doing and I'm
not hungover I love it we'll do this one
next today
might be my favorite red carpet look I
think we are at the premiere of dirty 30
and she is let it be known to the world
did this way before Selena Gomez did it
like in the middle part I was going very
Brigitte Bardot
yeah I had my spray tan rockin man there
was so much sweat inside at that leather
day Wow
I believe your spray tan stayed on I
mean me too I thought I was gonna look
like some weird drip pop art I love love
love this look because I also loved your
look that night the small the small Oh
God did a lot your life your look my
favorite part was the photos of us after
when I was a stewardess your aren't
Amazonian goddesses are seven foot long
legs that we got spray tan I think it's
like presenting yeah mamrie and gray I
was like to your left you'll see the
Grand Canyon Maya dad's about this game
but I am like if you hold that zipper
did this matter the dress came out for
that yeah it's a functional zipper did
you not see her all night going like
this okay the bottom up I missed my
flight the next morning to New York the
dirty thirty premiere party was
definitely a party when I partied like I
was still in my 20s but it's also
because they gave us the caveat that we
have to be at the plane in the morning
so I think we all have this natural
rejection to like control by someone
else but as soon as they tell us we have
to be somewhere in the morning me go
watch this I was in the cab headed to
LAX and they're like your flights out of
Burbank oh my god we were still drunk
from the night before and then they were
like neighbor didn't make it like all
right here's the next one
yeah this is from a video in which I was
like hey the name trolls on the Internet
I was like a bad connotation
I love trolls let's be treasure trolls
and grant wishes and someone's wish was
for me to make a pizza on Hannah's face
I remember being out of town when you
guys shot this video and then I watched
it I was like there's two things one
Hannah stuffed her bra she just kept
doing that chicken all night feel like
also Hannah was so soon hi Eliza tonight
and then you got so stoned then you're
good timer this [ __ ] predicted my
favorite personal love you had such a
pure reaction to seeing yourself you
don't know this is when Hannah was on
her first tour before we ever started no
filter tour and grace and I surprised
her out of bowling alley in Canada I'm
wearing ghillie suits which are hunting
suits it was startling I thought to
myself who loves to frolic in some
foliage face [ __ ] you know why I love
this outfit hmm because if you got drunk
at a field party mm-hmm
you sleep in a field party I'm from
North Carolina y'all give me those
comments saying you've been to a field
party come on now well there we go
there's a trip down memory a memory Hart
Lane
that's really amazing Thanks if you
haven't already ordered pre-ordered etc
and gone to a bookstore seen maimry on
her tour just click all the links in
description box below get this book go
see mamrie if she's coming to a town
near you go watch the video we made on
how miss Chen I'll go watch the video we
made our memories channel become a
citizen of meme to house look you
deserve a drink after seeing those
photos to me and she's got this round
Hey I don't know Jesus ever get that
feeling for you miss tortoise I got a
helper ma'am oh my god and you don't
want to see my little noodles coz your
brothers are in the second you know she
can't eat most me okay